[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud
and do not give a [__]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [__]
eating [__] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [__] em
[Music]
girl you in trouble you endangered girl
danger danger danger lady G
what do you think did you think he
flipped is that what you think
I mean there's only a few possibilities
here of why Lindsey Graham David Perdue
Kelly loffler Mike Flynn Linwood do you
remember Linwood this character
it's been a long time since I've heard
the name Linwood holy [__] that guy's
nuttier and squirrel turds by the way
actually squirrel turds are really
jealous
of Linwood
I don't know if you remember who Lynn
wood was was is the key word this is the
guy who uh he he was a lawyer he's not
anymore every [__] every one of these
people who were lawyers aren't lawyers
because of trump you ever notice that
you notice how that works out for them
did you know Lindsey Graham's a lawyer
well he might not be much longer I don't
know
also the DC grand jury is reconvening I
guess maybe maybe when the I.T guy down
at Mar-A-Lago uh got immunity
for his uh testimony against Trump
someone's like whoa you could get
[__] immunity to testify against this
guy maybe they reconvene the grand jury
to uh give immunity to someone I don't I
don't know yeah you know what nothing
nothing is going to surprise me from
here on out it's just not gonna surprise
me
at all
I don't think there's any surprises
waiting around the corner Republicans
are a criminal Enterprise folks
full stop the whole [__] thing is all
[__] criminals I mean did you see
the letter that Bonnie Willis
basically told Jim Jordan [__] around
find out [__]
[__] around find out just do it just try
it just try me
the whole thing up one sound side and
down the other it's a criminal
Enterprise
they've abandoned all policy they've
abandoned all principles they've been
they've abandoned all all [__] truth
and it's nothing but lies in crime over
there
hell I told you the other day the only
reason why people are still voting for
these [__] idiots is lies in
affiliation
that's it
that's it what else are they gonna vote
for
that Joe Biden's Banning ceiling fans
and Bud Light is gay come on now you
think you think those are policy
platforms at the Republican Party are
gonna be able to run on get the [__] out
of here
and to see three United States senators
one of them sitting
the the
uh lady G from South Carolina the
setting senator
because that's the that's really the the
big news this morning is that somehow
three United States senators
somehow three sitting United States
senators at the time that this was going
on Kelly loffler David Perdue and
Lindsey Graham
from the special grand jury not the
criminal grand jury but the special
grand jury
their recommendation was that they
indict those three senators
inside the RICO case
now I'm not sure what happened you know
I mean there's a lot of things from the
time that the the special grand jury
made the recommendations and the
criminal grand jury voted to indict the
19 defendants that are the defendants
there's a lot of [__] that happened in
there
I mean we know that as most of the state
electors the fake State electors that
were you know fraudulently beat trying
to be State electors for Trump a lot of
them flipped
so did Lindsey Graham did David Perdue
did Kelly loffler flip
is that why Trump went to Georgia in the
beginning of January to stump for them
so that he would trade their win
for them to try to overturn the election
I don't know how the [__] are we
supposed to know this stuff
it seems it seems kind of fishy and then
the fact that Mike Flynn was recommended
Mike Flynn
that [__] criminal [__] I
don't know if you remember this but Mike
Flynn
is the one who made the phone calls to
Russia during the transition and then he
lied to the FBI about it and then Trump
fired him as the National Security
adviser
do you remember that
that's been a long time ago and oh yeah
Mike Flynn was awarded a pardon from
Donald Trump hmm
it just you know it all seemed all seems
like
we don't have to far to realize that the
Republican are a criminal Enterprise
because it's not just a trump crime
family at this point [__] hell no it
ain't just a trump crime family
if you're a Republican and you're in
you're holding office in the Republican
Party hey you might be a criminal right
thank you
I don't know I mean that's where you
gotta start now
we're trying to figure out who these
people are
I mean did you ever think did you ever
think
when Lindsey Graham was speaking out
against Donald Trump in 2016 remember he
was calling him he was calling him a
[__] clown and he would destroy the
Republican party did you ever imagine
that Trump would hold that Lindsey
Graham is gay over him that's that's
what it is
you know everyone beats around the bush
what does Trump have over Lindsey Graham
he's he's gay he's a closeted gay man
and he doesn't want it to get out in
South Carolina that he's that because he
won't be elected
in South Carolina same way as the other
senator from South Carolina same [__]
thing same thing you know how many you
know how many of these Republic which I
don't have a problem with that I don't
care if Tucker Carlson Lindsey Graham
and Tim Scott uh and any of them I don't
Mike Pence it doesn't bother me if
they're closeted that's what they choose
to do that's if you know if that's what
you want to do with your life fine you
have the Liberty to do that in this
country no one's gonna [__] No One's
Gonna [__] put put judgment on you I
don't give a [__] just don't be going
around telling everyone else who they
can and can't love and who they can and
can't [__] that's all I'm saying
but don't just it match lap there's
another one
I mean we the the we go on and on and on
and on
but that's what it is that's that's what
Trump has over Lindsay
is they were cocaine sex orgies that
Lindsay was going to
they just weren't you know
anyways everyone wonders why Lindsey
Graham genuflex the Trump that that's
what it is
what do you think all them golf matches
were about what do you think the talk
was
on the golf course huh
but in 2016 when we were listening to
Lindsey Graham called Donald Trump a
chucklehead and he would destroy the
Republican party I guess he wasn't wrong
I mean maybe he knew at that point that
oh man if he becomes president finds out
what he finds out about me and tries to
use that I'll definitely capitulate to
him
because he'll blackmail me
and it appeared with Lindsey Graham may
have done some of that at some point
capitulate the Trump because there was
blackmail but the question is
the question is really did Lindsey
Graham flip on Trump did Mike Flynn flip
on Trump did Lynn wood flip on Trump did
Purdue did loffler flip on Trump and
there are several others those are just
the key names here that's the names that
everyone knows and who else is flipping
on Trump
we know his I.T guy down at Mar-A-Lago
is like [__] you dude I'm not going to
prison for your fat dumb ass no [__]
way you don't pay me enough to be the
I.T guy down here at Marlo you know he's
getting paid [__] oh you know it [__]
yeah you know it there's no way that it
guy was getting paid decent [__]
wages
he probably wasn't even receiving the
median income that people in his field
were receiving at Mar-A-Lago [__] no
Bob Trump wasn't paying him [__]
you can't convince me otherwise Pride me
evidence then I might change my mind but
until then I'm going with what I know
about Donald Trump he wasn't paying him
[__]
hell he paid more for his [__]
attorney to make sure that he didn't
flip on Trump then he probably paid him
a year's salary
[__] that guy Trump
and the ID guy is like [__] you buddy
but when he got to the to the
the criminal defense attorney that was
provided to him the public defender the
public defender's like flip on this
[__] we'll get you immunity
oh they want to give immunity to anybody
at this point son of a [__] maybe
Lindsey Graham got maybe Lindsey Graham
got some sort of immunity to testify in
front of the criminal grand jury in
Georgia who knows
we don't know at this point I bet we're
gonna find out
I bet we're gonna find out
just how criminal the Republican
organization is it's a it's a [__]
it's a [__] nincompoop Nazi mob is
what it is
oh God and they're holding it together
with [__] strings
and really honestly the Republican party
is dead
I mean that's really the story this
morning the Republican party is [__]
dead
we're just dragging around this dead
body around the country and pretending
as if we have two major parties
Jim Jordan Jim Jordan
decided he was going to obstruct
in a criminal prosecution and funny
Willis is like look [__]
you're obstructing in this criminal
prosecution here's you a couple court
cases to show you how you can't do that
[__]
and it's unconstitutional for you to do
that [__] so [__] around find out
and if anyone doesn't think that Bonnie
Wills will do something holy [__]
oh my God
she's the one that will
I mean I think history is going to tell
a lot of stories here right like we're
in this time right now we don't know
exactly what's going to happen
we don't know exactly what's going to
happen
not exactly I mean we got a good idea
right I mean [__]
not not only not only is this
[__] charged with 91 felonies
but the evidence the public evidence
alone is stacked against his defense
I showed you the tape yesterday of him
on Hugh Hewitt Show like I'm not telling
you anything I'm not telling you
anything uh but I get on the stand I'll
get on the stand and I'll claim that I
have the right to do whatever I want
with the presidential records act which
isn't a thing it's not a thing that's
not a thing it has nothing to do with it
not a goddamn thing they didn't charge
you under any statutes of the
presidential records act and not only
that the presidential records act
doesn't protect him
it protects the Office of the President
see that's the thing he doesn't [__]
understand
he didn't get it that he's not the
president that he held the office
he's not a king
he didn't know that though
he's a [__] idiot
but we know what he did he's saying it
out loud even with January 6.
with this election interference RICO
case in Georgia he's like it was a
perfect phone call perfect phone call
the [__] out of here Mark Meadows is in
federal court saying yeah goddamn right
I organized a phone call for him because
he would yell at me and throw ketchup at
me
I mean in all basic terms
that's not the exact quote pretty
[__] close though
now Donald Trump's trying to get his
Georgia case in federal court this is
all uh in an effort to delay
it's all in an effort to delay and the
and the reason why is because federal
courts are slow
I don't know what how many times I have
to prove it to you that federal courts
are slow and any illegal analysts that
you're listening to acting like there's
a rocket docket and boy he's gonna go to
trial tomorrow is [__] dumb
I'll give you a good example
yesterday Peter Navarro within a few
minutes
and it was minutes oh I'm gonna show you
this clip oh my God
this woman holding the sign with the
whistle she's after my heart hmm she's
after my heart but yesterday there's
another clip of Peter Navarro after him
he was found guilty it's kind of funny
it's almost like Peter Navarro wanted to
be found guilty because he called No
Witnesses he had no defense he had no
evidence
it's almost like you know when you have
no defense you have no Witnesses no
evidence to the contrary you're guilty
and the jury found that very quickly you
know what the funny part is
I'm I'm right about the federal system
because guess what he was he was found
guilty yesterday on September 7th 2023.
right he was found guilty by a jury now
now in federal federal courts you have
to have a separate sentencing you know
in most cases
we see that across the board it's not
complicated to understand that these are
the facts it really is not complicated
to know that in federal court they don't
do the sentencing right there when the
jury finds you guilty some states do but
in federal court they don't do that it's
a thing
well guess what Peter Navarro isn't
going to get sentenced till January and
guess what's gonna guess guess what's
gonna happen you guys can put this in
the doubt me thing on Discord guess
what's going to happen Peter Navarro is
going to be sentenced to three to six
months somewhere in that range three to
six months just like Steve Bannon and
they're going to let him out on appeal
that shit's gonna happen bet [__] bet
that's what's gonna happen and and I
mean Steve Bannon has been out on appeal
for what over a year now
federal courts work really fast don't
they come on now and if anyone's telling
you any different don't believe them
Stop Believing [__] that ain't real and
the [__] that ain't real that federal
courts go fast they don't go that fast
they don't
especially Criminal Courts so just and
and really honestly yesterday the Peter
Navarro trial was [__] delayed like
nine [__] months
so this idea that somehow the March 4th
there's going to be a trial for Trump
and DC and he's going to be oh he's
going to be found guilty in two days and
then they're going to send him off to
prison the next week
it's all a bunch of hooey
all of it
and again I I'm not here to make you
feel good about it I'm here to set your
expectations so you're not [__]
disappointed so you don't disengage or
the country doesn't get disengaged
that's the [__] point
we got to stay engaged in this we gotta
set our [__] heels in
on this election because we are the jury
It Is Us
not know 12 people in DC not know 12
people down in in South Florida or in
Georgia or in Manhattan or even in New
York against the the civil case that
Tish James is bringing against the Trump
organization
they are not the jury that are going to
bring down Donald Trump it is US folks
and it's time we start [__] acting
like it across the board
it's time we get involved in this time
we get engaged in this activity and not
be complacent to the fact that we can't
let the justice system be our savior
here
and just because you get mad because I
say something that you don't like well
think about it
at least I'm making you think that's the
thing I want and get angry get mad use
your strategic outrage
to point it towards saving our democracy
instead of relying on someone else to
save it for us because they're not going
to we cannot rely on the doj judge
Cannon judge chutkin Jack Smith Bonnie
Willis Tish James on the Manhattan D.A
to save our democracy it is our job our
job to do that so let's do our [__]
job and dump this piece of [__] in the
trash where he belongs and the rest of
the criminal GOP
it's a criminal organization it's time
we [__] show them who we are as a
country that we're not going to put up
with this [__]
[__] down in Georgia trying to
overturn elections three United States
senators three of them two of them from
the state of Georgia
trying to overturn elections there was
enough evidence that the special grand
jury recommended they be indicted
so I don't know what the evidence was
against them exactly but there was
enough evidence for the recommendation
now why they didn't get charged that's
another question
but this morning there should be there
should be calls for Lindsey Graham to
resign now you should not be a sitting
United States Senator you are a [__]
criminal you are you are [__] [__]
with elections in another state using
your [__] seat of power that your
constituents gave you enough you're a
[__] criminal resign [__] you
remember Al Franken do you remember this
[__] he had a stage picture of acting
like he was grabbing someone's boobs and
that was it he was done as a senator one
of the smartest [__] Senators one of
the hardest working Democrats we had in
this country one of the ones who were
defending [__] democracy and frankly
the [__] should still be a
United States Senator
and we're gonna let Lindsey Graham try
to overturn elections in Georgia to the
fact that a special grand jury would
recommend that he get criminally
indicted in a RICO case I don't give a
[__] what he did to not get indicted he
should resign now and every [__]
minute of Lindsey Graham's life from now
until the moment he's not a United
States Senator should be calls of why
aren't you resigning why won't you say
what did you do not to be charged
[__]
huh that's what we should be doing
not worrying about cameras in courtrooms
are the 14th Amendment
let's go after the heart of the criminal
organization let's take down the GOP
it's enough of this [__] Lindsey Graham
said it himself he will destroy the
Republican party and let's get on with
it
let's stop dragging around this dead
body of the gqp
let's take it out back did the grave and
throw the dirt on him it's enough of
this [__]
that's what we need to do just like Tish
Jane or excuse me fonnie Willis two
black women
are gonna [__] be in history
of of who [__] with Donald Trump
or who he [__] with really and found
out
Bonnie Willis told Jim Jordan just try
it [__]
try it do it [__] and I hope Jim
Jordan does I hope Jim Jordan is on the
phone with Donald Trump and he's [__]
bending his knee to Donald Trump and
he's gonna do whatever criminal thing
Donald Trump tells that criminal
[__] Jim I don't report sex
crimes Jordan to do
same way with James Comer you criminal
pieces of [__] and you ain't gonna get
out of this Ted Cruz and Josh Holly same
[__] way just as well as Ron Johnson
and Chuck Grassley are part of this
criminal organization they knew the plan
they knew what the coup was gonna be
they knew they [__] knew and they
helped them
United States senators sitting Senators
sitting members of Congress sedition
and what are we gonna do about it
We the People
are gonna be their jury
and that's the way it should be because
let me tell you something Josh hawley's
up
in Missouri and there's a hell of a
candidate Lucas Koontz I'm gonna get him
on the show
I'm gonna get him on this show and we'll
talk to Lucas
we can do this folks
Ted Cruz ha funny Ted Cruz is up for
election too guess what we'll be your
jury Ted Cruz you seditious [__]
they were all in on it every last
[__] one of them
don't let him fool you Ron Johnson
having his staff carry over fake
electors to the vice president give me a
[__] break
every last [__] one of the GOP it's
criminals and let me tell you something
if you got an R next year your name you
better you better scratch it if you
don't want to be part of the criminal
organization
I'm gonna do everything in my [__]
power from now until the end of time to
let people know how much of a criminal
organization the GOP is and how deep the
rot goes
deep State my [__] ass you're the
Deep State you're the [__] swamp
always projection
with these fascist [__] every
last single time trying to take our
rights away trying to steal our [__]
elections trying to steal our voice
[__] that [__] get mad
use your cathartic and your strategic
outrage to aim
to get on the battlefield of the ballot
and let's engage in our democracy and
let's do democracy and end end
the criminal Republican party it's
enough of this [__]
they're terrified so terrified that they
won't even they won't even Cast Away
Mitch McConnell that's their best line
of defense Kevin McCarthy capitulating
giving Trump Cheeto dust fellatio so
that he could keep his power and keep
his job
Jim Jordan and Jim Jordan and Jim James
Comer doing the same exact thing
committing crime
crime
against our democracy
at the behest
of a [__] of a [__] indicted
Criminal
91 failing counts including Ricoh
charges for election interference
and you're talking about weaponization
of government Jim Jordan [__] you
it's time we get pissed it's time we act
pissed
I'm telling you
stop listening to the media heads stop
listening to the [__] polls they're
all a bunch of [__] all of it stop
[__] getting so worked up over
criminal trials just start politicizing
every [__] issue starting with
Lindsey Graham Donald Trump Rudy
Giuliani loffler Purdue Ted Cruz Josh
Hawley Ron Johnson every [__] one of
them
who else is going to ask these people
these questions besides the media are
they going to stand around
are they going to stand around trying to
figure out oh well who's going to be
trapping in the primaries who's gonna
beat No One's Gonna beat Trump in the
primaries
who's gonna be on the No Labels ticket
is going to be CR the No Labels ticket
is a pro-trump
simple it's for Trump
it's time we pluck our heads out of our
own asses and get with it here
get with it I'll tell you a good example
before we go to break here's a good
example oh my God they're terrified of
the phrase pro-life folks we have done
it we have done it for years these
[__] fascists stood on the stood on
the back of the the messaging of
pro-life and they're abandoning it
that's right because they're not
pro-life they never [__] were their
anti-woman
they never were [__] pro-life it was
all [__]
the Senators the Republican senators in
Mitch McConnell had a [__] meeting on
how they can get rid of the phrase
pro-life I'm not [__] you and they
want to go with Pro baby that's what
they want to go with
good luck to you [__] what about the
babies being killed in elementary
schools because you won't do anything
about guns in our communities huh you'll
give guns to any [__] any crazy
[__]
and you're and you're Pro baby you're
not pro baby you're anti-woman
your auntie woman
pro-life Pro baby get the [__] out of
here you were locking up babies at the
goddamn border you're setting up razor
wire
so that so that babies can't come to
this country to have a better life
and your pro baby get the [__] out of
here
you're gonna have to do better than that
Republicans way better than that we're
gonna crush up
their messaging we've already have and
they really they did it themselves
with the reversing of Roe v Wade who
would have thought the phrase pro-life
would really go down the [__]
when they put women's lives at danger
because they're banning Women's Health
Care
there's your prime example folks you
want some you want to [__] engage you
want to Target the Republican criminal
crime family that's where you target
them right there pro-life Pro baby baby
that's it
there's you some politicization there's
just some narrative there's where you
draw wedges Let them fight over what
dumbass phrase they're gonna lie about
them being anti-woman you know what I
just wish what I wish the Republican
their establishment Republican arm would
do would just finally go on the Andrew
Tate side of things they're trying to
attract the Andrew Tate [__] audience
these [__] white male incels who live
in their [__] mom's basement
anyways that's who they're [__]
attracting why don't they just do that
they're like we hate women honestly the
Republicans would be better off if they
just said what they really want and the
reason why is because of people like me
because I'm not going to let them get
away with the [__] pro-life Pro baby
[__] anymore
not gonna do it I'll say the absolute
[__] truth no matter what words need
to come out of my mouth
and the reason why is because no one no
one can [__] stop me and it's because
of you
no one can stop me from saying what the
[__] I want to say the way that we need
it said
because of you
there's no corporate sponsor here that
can say Tony look we'll cancel your
contract I ain't got no corporate
sponsors
one reason is because of my [__]
mouth
maybe that's by Design maybe it's a good
thing that they can't stop me from
saying anything there's no one else that
can stop me from saying [__] not one of
them
not a single [__] can call me
and tell me to stop saying whatever the
[__] it is I need to say
what needs to be said
it's been enough of beating around the
bush and being nice
trying to oh boy we really oh we need to
have decorum decorum
they're trying to steal Women's Health
Care away they are they're trying to
exterminate our countrymen
they're burning books they're making
they're making little children have
[__] babies they're forcing them to
be pregnant
and carry babies to term they're lying
about women's health care to steal it
away from them
and you want to have decorum
what do you think this is other than a
fight
when you get in that boxing ring you
better put on your boxing gloves and boy
you better throw some [__] punches
and you better come at them because
they're not gonna stop they're not gonna
quit
I wish they would and maybe one of these
days maybe 20 years from now
I don't have to yell and scream so
goddamn loud into this microphone maybe
I can guess corporate sponsors by then
because I don't have to say crazy ass
[__] the [__] that needs to be said
and again the reason why I can say it is
because you
you are the ones who keep me on this
microphone no one else
you are the one
so rather you love my rhetoric or you
hate it
or you think I go too far or you think I
curse way too [__] much
just know this know this it's the [__]
that needs to be said
and I won't quit
and I don't have to quit because of you
the audience
the support you give us
here at this show
to make sure that what needs to be said
is said don't go anywhere we'll be right
back right after this
we'll be right back
Mark 60 seconds this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capital have you been left out in
the cold after stealing Nancy Pelosi's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi I'm Paul gosar and thanks to
my new product pardon blanket I've got
you covered part in blanket specifically
Works to make you feel safe and cozy
after your involvement on January 6th
and if you're one of the other members
of Congress who also helped with the
attempted coup hard in blanket will
protect you too hard and blanket is made
of a sort of soft fleece and a layer of
sheep's wool and they're a hundred
percent made in the USA don't delay and
get your pardon blanket today for just
99.99 actual pardons not guaranteed
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
welcome back to the show speaking of
showing support go show Gabe Sanchez
some support you know we're gonna be
expanding the [__] fam universe
heard the news
[Music]
Dave Sanchez is gonna be what was that
live what was that live directly after
this show on Tuesdays Wednesdays and
Thursdays
the ghost show Gabe Sanchez some support
for his new live show that will appear
and it will happen right after this show
you won't have to do anything if you're
on the YouTube channel it'll go directly
to Gabe's show on Tuesdays Wednesdays
and Thursdays now he's still going to
join me on Monday
and he's going to join me on Friday like
today in the second hour for bonehead of
the week boy we have a lot of boneheads
it is a little difficult to be going on
us this morning I'm like man I really
don't want to double dip
because if I talk about this one and I
talk about that one then we do this
again I'm like Jesus Christ
it's Alana it's a lot of it's a lot of
boneheads
I mean when you're a big criminal
organization like the Republican party
you're gonna end up having some
boneheads in it but go support Gabe
Sanchez for our new schedule and here
here is the Tony michaels.com if you
want to hit subscribe up here at the top
I'll get you any kind of new new news
that comes with the links every day I
send you the new link for the show so
you'll get that in your email you can
also support me but the thing I want you
to do is roll on down here it says
Gabe's Sanchez merch click on that that
goes to his link tree
and go to this link tree and follow his
YouTube channel follow him everywhere
really go check out his patreon page
give Gabe some support uh again next
week he's going to be doing his own what
was that live show
right after this one so if you're on
YouTube and twitch twitch also will will
do like a raid
um it's a little different than like
what it is on YouTube but they do a raid
where you go over to his channel and
then you're gonna you're gonna sit and
watch your show on Tuesday Wednesday
Thursday for a full hour of what was
that live so make sure to go to I am
Gabe saidchez.com go to his link tree go
to his YouTube channel make sure you're
following him everywhere and check out
his patreon page because he's still
gonna have all the extras like the
weekend extras and his clips and stuff
like that he's going to do the certain
planning sessions with you guys
his show what was that live is just
going to be getting to those topics that
he can't do or what was that for because
they're so [__] many of them and this
next year is just gonna be a goddamn
waterfall
of moments that Gabe Sanchez is gonna go
what was that so make sure that you
follow the show here and also follow
Gabe's YouTube channel because it will
be on Gabe's YouTube channel
the show will be on Gabe's YouTube
channel but it'll direct directly to the
link now when he starts his show also if
you want to get your own pardon blanket
you can go to Gabe Sanchez's merch store
and get your very own pardon blanket
they're real they are [__] real
so go to the Tony michaels.com you can
find all Gabe's links there as well as
getting in on my links if you want to do
that again you should subscribe at the
very top of the page hit subscribe I'll
send you any of the updates that are
happening uh for that you can buy me a
shot I want to thank everyone who's
buying me a shot I did a video and I'm
going to post that video I think over on
Discord and for you guys to look at
speaking of that if you want to join the
Discord the Link's down here now the
Discord link if you want to join the
Discord also if you want to send a venmo
super chat today if you want to get your
chat on screen don't forget you can send
the venmo Super Chat just go to the Tony
michaels.com hit the Super Chat venmo
Super Chat link and you can check out my
patreon page because I'm going to be
doing a pre-show on Mondays and Fridays
next week we'll be doing a pre-show and
I think what we're going to do
is we're gonna do it in Discord it makes
sense like a private room and Discord so
if you're a patreon member I'm gonna
figure out how to get all that done and
we're going to figure out what what
level the 20 level is definitely going
to get you in the pre-show and above but
I'm gonna figure all that out this
weekend and then this weekend on the
Sunday rant for patreon only
I'm gonna let you guys know for sure
exactly how hopefully I'll have by then
exactly how everything will work on
Mondays and Fridays for the pre-show for
you guys to watch the pre-show and it's
more like a producer's corner it's not
going to be like the show here it's
going to be like prepping for the show
so you guys are going to get to see like
behind the scenes you're gonna get to
help me figure out what stories you want
on the show what you don't so if you
want to get in on that pre-hour on
Mondays and Fridays go to patreon.com
the Tony Michaels or you can go to the
Tony michaels.com click on the support
Tony on patreon
you can find that there and we will go
over that and I'll probably make this
Sunday's Sunday rant public so everyone
can kind of see what's going to happen
and that way you know exactly what it's
going to be for for the pre-hour
because I'm not even really sure I just
know we're gonna do a pre-hour we're
gonna hang out we're going to talk about
what we're going to talk about on the
show that week so we're going to do
Mondays and Fridays as a pre-hour so you
get possibly three hours on Monday and
Friday and then on Tuesday Wednesday
Thursday you're going to have the two
hour show plus an hour of Gabe so we're
getting the three hours per day that's
how we're doing it we're expanding here
at the [__] fam Universe uh hopefully
we'll expand even more past this maybe
we'll expand even more passes and have
more content
um and then this weekend I'll also
announce the uh the sign up if you are
interested in being a moderator on
whatever platform that we have I'm gonna
get a sign up sheet because we're just
trying to collect names because I know
we're we're gonna need more we're gonna
need more people help moderating now
just because with the expansion there's
so much time so we're going to need a
few more people to help so if you're
interested in that I'm gonna have you
fill out a form that way we have a list
of people who are interested and it
might take us a while to go through it
uh but but we'll go through it and
figure out who who will work best on
what platform to be moderators and then
you'll be on the list you'll be on the
list of moderators if we ever need any
more uh if it continues to be to where
we have to have moderators in the mix in
the mix so here's the schedule I'll post
that one more time here on the screen so
on Mondays and Fridays you'll get a
pre-hour
with me if you're on the patreon only
and then you'll have the show of course
the show is free the two-hour the Tony
Michaels podcast and on Tuesday
Wednesday Thursday the what was that
live it's going to be open it's going to
be public you'll get to see it no matter
what no matter if you're patreon on
Gabe's patreon or not the what was that
live will be live live live to the
public so you get to see that as well
that's I'm very excited about next week
I don't know exactly how it's all you're
gonna have to you have to give us like
two or three weeks to get used to it you
know what I mean it's gonna take a
little bit to get used to the new
schedule but we'll get there
we'll get there you'll hang with us
because you're the best audience in the
world I I mean [__] she even hang with
me when I when I speak against people
that you love
and you like listen and do now when I
call them out on their [__]
it happens it happens speaking of
[__] let's um let's get to some
clips here Gabe Sanchez is going to join
us at the top of the hour
for bonehead of the week because it's
Friday
uh someone's answering
oh yes so on the level of patreon some
people are asking the level of patreon
so on um I will be announcing this
and this Sunday on the Sunday rant and
I'm gonna make the Sunday ramp public so
everyone can come see now when we do the
public the the Sunday rant we do it in
public it's at nine Eastern 8 P.M
Central so it's in the evening on Sunday
but you'll be able to come and check it
out it'll be public it'll be on the
YouTube and I'm gonna go over exactly
who's gonna get what on the patreon how
it's going to work what you have access
to and we'll go through all that with
the new
with what's happening all the new
changes that are happening
um so don't forget if you want to
participate in the new stuff that's
going to happen or you're wondering
about what patreon level if you're
considering joining patreon or you're
upgrading because I notice a lot of
people upgraded because I said the 20
the 20 the 20 tier is going to be like
the the threshold for the for the
pre-hour but the the people below like
the five and ten you're still gonna get
some stuff from the new the new things
that we're doing like on Discord and
some members only stuff over on Discord
so uh just on Sunday if you're
interested in all that come watch that
live or watch it after it's recorded
I'll make it public so everyone can see
it so if you're interested in joining or
you're interested in knowing exactly
what you're going to get with what come
Sunday I'm going to be transparent about
it and we're going to say exactly what
you're gonna get and how it's going to
work so
um just know that and and also go join
the Discord that's what you're going to
want to do is join the Discord and I
know a lot of people are like why are we
keep talking about Discord the reason
why is because we're building a
community over there I don't know if you
if you've been over there to check it
out but we're really building a
community over there
it's like our own little [__] fam
social media spot right so it's it's
really it's really cool over there it's
not just it's not just for the live show
it's and it's not just
um for like the patreon stuff there's a
lot of cool stuff going on over there
again it's like it's our own personal
little [__] fam social media Gabe's
over there I'm over there you can talk
to us now yeah storm Virgil says it's
literally a community like a clubhouse
you can talk to each other in like a in
like a chat like literally talk with
voices you can be on camera uh there's
opportunities where you can watch other
stuff that's streaming they stream stuff
over there all the time documentaries
other other people's content stuff off
YouTube that they found
um they're sharing stuff all around so
it's not just it's not again Liberty
1920 says [__] up Clubhouse it really is
kind of a clubhouse over there but when
you go join when you click into join
make sure you verify
um so that they know you're a human
because that's how we keep it all
underground you know in check over there
and that's another place that we may
need some moderators so I'm I'm gonna
fill out that form if you want to be a
moderator I'm going to give you that
link this weekend during the show during
the Sunday rant so you're going to want
to be there for that and I will give you
the ability to sign up to be on the list
to be considered as a as a moderator but
really honestly the Discord our Discord
is different than other discords so if
you're like I don't like Discord because
I've been on other discords this one is
not the same this one is not the same
our great Discord manager over there
Mighty librarian is doing a great job
organizing everything skip does a great
job organizing the stages and making
sure that moderate so again
again go join that Discord because it's
different than any other discords that
we have it really is a clubhouse over
there that you guys can you guys can
share ideas they have the Roundtable
democracy stuff they have cool things
like you know pictures of food you made
photos you've taken photos of stuff you
made the best memes there's piles and
piles and piles of memes over there if
you want to go grab some memes uh to
spread around and you know propagate
other social media sites that's over
there the patreon stuff will be over
there uh all all the videos that we post
here on YouTube they get posted
automatically over there so you get to
see all those videos uh right off
YouTube so you don't miss them if
there's no notification sent to you all
my doubt me stuff so all my predictions
that I make right you guys can hold me
to them over there there's a doubt me
channel so they put in all the
predictions that I make over there if we
miss one you can suggest one and it'll
we can put it in there that way you guys
can really you know hammer on me when
I'm wrong which I probably won't be
I probably won't be I really won't be so
check it out over there it's a great
comedian it's being built and I know
I've been harping on them you guys to
join Discord but I'm telling you our
Discord server over there is turning out
to be completely verified uh Jay Jay
says uh here she says I can't get
verified
um so Jay so this is a good question so
verification is important over there on
the Discord server because they just
want to make sure there's human it's
you're a human behind your account on
your Discord so just go to the welcome
center it's hashtag Welcome Center at
the very top it'll give you directions
and if you can't figure it out you can
tag uh who you can tag and they'll get
you uh verified so if you can't get
verified keep trying we're going to get
you verified over there I promise we'll
get you verified we'll get it taken care
of and we'll get you guys verified in
that so you can be part of the the
[__] fam community and the [__]
Clubhouse I kind of like that name the
[__] em Clubhouse you know what I mean
it's kind of cool I like that
you know we come up with all kinds of
stuff here so
let's see do we have any other questions
about the Discord I just want to make
sure but again I get over there get
verified uh let me put the link in the
chat one more time so you guys can see
it uh you know and I don't want you to
miss out on the Discord here so we'll
put the Discord right there in the chat
again and you can join Gabe's Discord
too Gabe is uh Gabe will be doing a lot
of stuff in his Discord but he's in our
Discord because we're all part of the
[__] Universe right we're all part of
the [__] fam uh so Gabe is in ours
he'll be in his uh so you know he's
building his what was that out over
there but the [__] fam community
is over there in the in the [__] them uh
everyone keeps wanting army green
[__] match I looked into this
yesterday and I I promise I'm gonna try
to get the the army green
um [__] em hats as soon as possible I
promise I'm I'm gonna try to get those
so I did look into it yesterday just
keep bugging me everyone knows that if
you just keep bugging me it's not that
I'm ignoring I just have a limited
amount of time to do everything so
um you know time is money I guess and
and I as you guys know I have a family
so I make good time for my family I make
time for this show I make time for
making content and being with you guys
and making sure we have the correct
thing and I try to keep up with all the
stories but I do make time for my family
that is something I intentionally do and
I appreciate that you guys that you guys
allow me to do that and I I'm serious
about that you guys allow me you guys
aren't pushy about oh you should do this
and give us more of this and this here
and that there you guys are very
appreciative anytime that I I have a
Sunday rant because I have a family
thing uh all the all the patreon over
there they're always understanding if I
have a family thing and I can't do a
Sunday rant you guys have always
understood that stuff
um so really honestly I appreciate it
and and I thank you for giving me the
opportunity to do this show because it
is I'm funded by viewers like you as PBS
says that is how I that's how the lights
stay on here that's how the microphone
stays on as viewers like you not just
paying whether you're paying for patreon
or you're buying shots or you're doing
venmo chats or you're just putting in
the tip jar you're buying merch
um all that stuff matters but being here
and engaging and being part of the
community and helping each other out
right like when we go over to um when
you guys go over to Discord and you're
having trouble verifying they're going
to help you out over there I promise
they're all there to help you they're
all there for you for you guys to talk
to and communicate with and have a
community over there I'm really I'm dumb
bounded about how quickly it has grown
over there into a real community of
people who are like-minded who love
democracy they disagree they don't
always agree on everything I mean [__]
they don't agree with me on everything
but we're all we're all in this together
is a pro-democracy coalition and I
really I really do think
um that that the community is where
we're going to build this thing and it's
what keeps it's what keeps the show
going and it's what keeps Gabe's show
going it's what keeps that content
coming out and keeps our voices out
there and I I know our our voices uh
because we have you behind us
they will matter and they will matter
more because you're behind us as opposed
to some corporate sponsor or some
Network or or some group of people who
want to sell advertising or whatever the
hell it is when we got your voices
behind us our voices are going to be
stronger and they can't stop us they
can't tell us what we can and can't say
I'm telling you uh Christina has a
comment here she says Tony I'm a patreon
subscriber and have a suggestion for the
name of the new patreon show great I saw
a few suggestions
um I forget someone but you say your
patreon show on Monday Wednesday how
about the [__] them [__] em warm-up
that's pretty good
that's pretty good now again Christina
says she you sent a message but it
didn't get a response I get a ton of DMS
Instagram patreon uh Discord and I and I
I have so many messages that you guys
type me out every day when we're doing
the show on Facebook
um on YouTube on Twitch uh on Discord
that it is hard for me to read every
single one of them so if I don't get to
your DM it's not because I'm ignoring
you or it's not because I haven't got to
it it's because I haven't got to it yet
and if you're trying to tell me
something don't stop dming me eventually
I might see it I'm not I promise I'm not
ignoring it's just I only have so much
time and really honestly I take a
certain part of my day to try to look at
messages and and I try to look at them
in different places so I'm not ignoring
ignoring like one place so I'm trying to
get to him I really I really try to get
to them so again if you're trying to
tell me something great give me great
because you guys you guys literally the
reason why I think this community is so
great is because you guys have helped
build this show like you guys have named
so many things the petty Yeti when we
call Marjorie Taylor green the petty
that came from the chat
um Hunter buying [__] committees that
came from the chat right
um smashed the fast that came from the
chat we're gonna have the smash the fast
art contest soon that came from the chat
um buy me a shot that came from the chat
you guys the reason why I come up with
buy me a shot on
um where you guys can buy me a Jager
shot
is everyone would keep saying like I
want to buy you a shot you'd send me DMS
over and over and I want to buy you a
shot I want to buy you a shot I want to
buy you a shot but you know what let's
just let them uh let you buy me
literally buy me a shot so so I
appreciate every single one of you I my
voice would be nothing without you I
want you to know that and that is the
[__] truth
the cold heart and you know I'm not
gonna I'm not gonna tell you any kind of
[__] the reason why my voice
resonates is because your voice is
behind it
and they can't stop that they cannot
stop if it's your voice behind me not
some like I said corporate sponsor a big
money backer or someone who wants to buy
part of my show or
anything like that it is you it is the
community and we will build this thing
to be big to where we will not we will
not stop and it'll go long past the 2024
election
this is not going to stop there I told
you I wouldn't stop after 2022 I'm not
stopping after 2024. we're gonna go long
after that and I'm I'm so happy that you
are on this journey with me
because that's what it's going to be a
journey in democracy because we're going
to do so many things and and accomplish
so many goals with just our voices
that is what is important we don't have
to always agree
we don't have to always be correct
we don't have to always read the future
exactly whether it's me or it's you
but what we have to do is fight for the
foundation and the institutions of
democracy
because those foundations and those
liberal institutions of Western
democracy will deliver us the equity and
equality I believe our future
Generations are looking for
we don't have it now but we can
accomplish it we can work towards it
it's a long hard fight because democracy
is difficult democracy is worth fighting
for though and we have the strength to
fight for it
we have the strength to save our
democracy and Advance it for it to be
better for the generations to come
and that's what's most important that's
the foundation that the [__] fam
stands on
and I know it feels weird that the word
[__] is always invoked here on this show
but there's something about it and there
there's something about the word [__]
that's a perfect protest
the perfect protest to say [__] them we
don't care we I'm not going to stop
saying what I'm saying because of your
corporate money [__] them I'm not going
to stop saying because it's because it
might not be politically
correct to not say it [__] them I'm not
gonna stop speaking out against the
criminal Republicans because you're not
supposed to call your political
opponents criminals [__] them
it's the perfect protest word [__]
and it's the perfect protest phrase [__]
them
and we're not gonna stop I'm not gonna
stop and I know you're not gonna stop
so let's take it to the bank and let's
keep going and let's show everyone in
the pro-democracy Coalition what the
word [__] means
and let's show them what it can
accomplish
because I know that sounds weird that
the word [__] can accomplish something
in a democracy
but I bet it can
and I bet it will
and the only reason why is because of
your voice
it's your voice
yes it is me talking into the microphone
but it is it is us we are the government
we are the democracy
and we are the people
and we need to get Gabe Sanchez on here
to be quite honest
bone end of the week I was going to show
you a couple uh links or uh Clips in the
meantime but um I'm gonna check and see
if he's almost ready so let's go to uh
some clips here
and that I have ready for you that I
found this morning
oh uh no I want to go you know what
let's start with this one here oh this
is a Dandy
speaking of speaking of crime families
[Music]
speaking of crime families Eric Trump
showed up on Julie Green's podcast
do you remember Julie green is we
featured here a couple times here on the
show she's the kooky lady that gets
emails from God
remember her I'm not [__] you this
lady thinks she's getting emails
she's getting emails from God
and Eric Trump was on her show and she
literally is sitting there saying that
yeah I get emails from God saying that
your dad is the is the chosen one
literally and he's like uh-huh uh-huh
uh-huh I'm not kidding you it's a thing
watch this it's crazy [__] I don't get
to make this stuff up and now you're
seeing certain segments of the
population like the African-American
segment of the population we're coming
down saying they've done the same crap
that they're doing to Donald Trump
they've done it to us for years they've
indicted us for nonsense they've thrown
the legal system at us they haven't
given us a chance in hell it's been a
raid system
um they've literally made my father a
martyr with with certain segments of the
population that they are oh my God okay
so I hope they keep going with this
narrative that somehow
somehow black people are like yeah
Donald Trump got his mug shot so he's as
oppressed as we are what the [__] are
you talking about
what the hell are you talking about
I mean no matter no you can say whatever
[__] you want to say Eric Trump and
and Republicans you can say whatever
listen there is one thing there is one
thing that the black community knows and
it's not that Donald Trump is oppressed
as black people okay
oh my God like have you been listening
to yourselves I mean Jesus Christ every
time every time they hear the word
Insurrection they're like black lives
matter and George Floyd should have been
murdered type [__] like really honestly
I don't think Donald Trump's mug shot is
gonna do it for him I just don't I
actually honestly I think they're gonna
be like maybe there is movement in the
two-tier justice system finally
because that's the fact of the matter
there is a two-tier justice system there
is one
there is one there's a two-tier justice
system
and the the lower tier isn't rich white
people like Eric Trump and Donald Trump
that's the upper tier the privileged
tier
and that's really what they're F that's
really what the [__] they're pissed off
about
is that the upper tier
is not protecting them anymore
honestly the reason why Donald Trump and
Eric Trump are so mad is because the
justice system is treating them like
what they would think it should treat
black people okay
it's not [__] hard to understand
these things Eric you [__] bonehead
but let's continue otherwise
you know claim to own and uh why I love
seeing it because there are so many
prophetic words talking about the exact
very thing what God's been saying what's
going to happen is now unfolding
so God intended God intended for Trump
to get indicted apparently God intended
for Trump to commit 91 [__] felonies
I guess isn't that what she's saying
that God's like you know what pep let's
get Donald Trump to commit some felonies
that will be great
God's like let's overturn democracy in
the United States let's do that get the
[__] out of here with this nonsense
let's continue though and that's why I
that's why we are all sit there and
we're standing here and we're just like
no matter what these people are doing
they are the ones who will be exposed no
matter what they're going to do and no
matter what they're going to try to do
to your dad it will not it will not go
the way they want it
okay all right so
wow this lady gets a couple emails from
God and she's gonna say that we're not
gonna have it the way we want it what
the [__] are you talking about what do
you mean the way we want it this is the
way he wanted it this is what he wanted
he wanted to try to overthrow the
government of the United States he
wanted to commit felonies when he stole
the documents and he wouldn't he
wouldn't give him back and he abstract
this is what he wanted this is not what
we wanted we did not want this I I wish
I wish we could turn back the clock to
be quite honest with you Donald Trump
lose he concede and he go the [__] away
and never [__] post on the internet
again never give a public statement
again just go hide out at Mar-A-Lago and
we wouldn't have to [__] indict him
and imprison him and convict him and all
this [__] no one wanted this but
Trump that's the problem that's why
people are so [__] sick and tired of
this [__] no one wanted this but Trump
he's the one who wanted it and to act
like an act to act like black people are
gonna sympathize with Trump because of a
mug shot get the [__] out of here no
email from God is gonna convince me or
Gabe Sanchez
that that somehow somehow the mugshot of
trump is going to get black people to go
oh well now now he knows how we feel
what the [__] is that what that's is
that what they're saying again oh well I
mean this is what Eric Trump is saying
on Julie uh greens the prophets uh you
know there was a mo there was a moment
where I was like I'm right now what was
that on the mug shot yeah and then you
know [__] the news happens and [__]
comes out oh you know oh you mean
there's like a thousand other crimes
that is exposed yeah there's like
another Republican criminals Republican
criminals you know I just I just wrapped
up uh filming and I'm doing the final
touches on editing the the VEC or Vivek
ramaswami no no yeah all right well I
had to save I had to save a vague
because there's a there's a couple lines
in there right it's specifically oh okay
so it's like a rhyme thing yeah yeah
exactly does he make a cake
and he rhymes with cake but he's also a
big goddamn [__] fake anyway oh
there's a lot of words that rhyme with
the vague yeah maybe it should be Vivek
I know it's not a good one [__] sake
you know it's like the the scene from
sorry from Happy Gilmore just go by the
bay make some eat some hay lay by the
bay I don't know what do you say I just
made
when I was so I had it I was like I'm
gonna do this I'm gonna do this uh what
was that on that and then time passed
and I was like I don't know it's really
relevant but thankfully because of that
Newsmax interview
I think it was Newsmax Newsmax interview
where
they said
um there could be legal recourse you
know for copyright which was a story
that was like you're you're talking
about the mugshots yeah and who owns it
didn't you put it on a mug
yeah yeah I put it on there well you
definitely shouldn't go you definitely
shouldn't go to I am Gabe sanchez.com
and go to the merch store and buy that
mug yeah no it's crazy you should not
buy a mug that or the Rudy Giuliani one
yeah it doesn't matter anyway are they
gonna come after me I highly doubt it
I'm not selling millions of dollars in
Grifton and fleecing people for a mug
shot but what I will say is anyway I was
gonna do a thing on the copyright
infringement I was like ah it's kind of
late now but thankfully because they
keep bringing this [__] up I can now do
it again sweet good yeah uh someone else
gives you another and I'm sure this is
in them what was that Vivek the snake so
there's another good word snake that
almost makes him sound cool though yeah
that's true that's like you know I'm a
snake
the snake the snake speaking of snake
let's finish this up with the prophet
Julie green and then we'll go to uh
bonehead of the week because I want to
keep it tight today keep it tight is
that is that zero days if I say that no
I don't know okay so that that's just
it's only a people's minds get in the
gutter when I say something like that
and that's their own personal counter
right yeah it's not the show scanner
that's an unofficial counter okay should
we put a counter over on this I think we
should put a counter or Discord let's
get to Julie green because she really
says massages this idea that somehow
Trump is the messiah in front of Eric
Trump and I think he gets a a boner to
hater bait over it but let's see oh yeah
it will not go the way they want it
because God's on his side and he's
called him as David he said as anointed
as a point in one he said it more than
once he continually doesn't say it I've
had so many different prophetic words
regarding your father and the Lord I've
cried because I knew the love that God
has for him the love that God has for
your family did you see uh Eric Trump
kind of getting us he was getting a
boner he really oh yeah which he's like
oh yeah your your dad's the David he's
the Messiah he's the prophet and God is
told he's emailed me he emails me all
the time saying how great your dad is I
just I can't wait to meet the person who
and also Eric Trump is the only one who
is like
quasi-religious in that family he's the
only one that shows up to those weird
ass [__] but it's only in the last
few years right like this yeah
before I'd say in the last like maybe
two years I'd have to go back and go do
some sleuthing but I definitely know
this last year and the year before that
is what he's been showing up to those
televised Evangelical it's not a not
necessarily a mega church but it's
pretty big and he goes up there I think
it's the same one that Mike Flynn has
been to all these other Patriots Mike
Flynn you mean the guy who wasn't
criminally indicted but was recommended
to be criminally indicted in Georgia
yeah oh my God the [__] Discord I say
Eric has a boner
and then I'll go over I'll go during
I'll go during bonehead of the week once
that's cleared up that's what Eric Trump
said I'll give it a minute and see if it
but it's not gonna you're gonna have to
get the boner account uh so let's let's
finish up here and then we'll go to Bone
we'll go to boner of the week I mean
bone end of the week and I could just
feel it and it's like he's not going to
let he's not going to forsake you and
he's not going to let this continue
I I hope that Eric Trump and Donald
Trump believe this woman that she's
getting emails from God like something
deep down inside me wants to be like I
actually think that's real and and that
those emails are real and that I'm going
to be protected because God emails Julie
green and says that I'm going to be
protected like I'm continuing to I'm I'm
gonna I'm you know at this point I'm
like quintupling down on the fact that
there is someone out there who is
sending her emails
from something that looks like it's
addressed from God
and she she you know they probably
emailed her one time and they said
something they quoted some scripture you
know uh John this that whatever and then
probably reference something that's
happening in current events like maybe
that news just broke and so she's like
oh it has to be God because no one else
would know to email me this
[Laughter]
oh my God I want to know what kind of
party you're having tonight now now I
want a collection of emails from Satan
that we can read on air uh emails emails
from Satan is that is that exciting is
that how Satan talks well he's you know
he's got a little twine to him you know
does he ruin him you know
it kind of like Lindsey Graham is that
we got a little a little bit like
Lindsey Graham a little bit like lady
Jim a bit like ladies G oh my God just
saying sane's here to have a good time G
Satan doesn't hate you Satan doesn't
hate you whatever you do what your
gender what your sexuality is
Satan's just here have a good time is he
is he here to have a good time he's
having a good time oh my God Lindsey
Graham Lindsey Graham Lindsey Graham
what what a great story speaking of
great stories let's get to bonehead of
the week yeah I gotta I gotta get to the
uh the folder here so I can get the [__]
out of it is it all in there is it good
he's been there for like
20 minutes 30 minutes I was talking I
was talking the audience
is it here is it here is it here it is
here let's see who do we got here we got
that one that one oh speaking of Lady G
all right so let's do this let's go to a
break when we come back okay
of the week we're gonna get
seeing a few
we'll be right back
mark
60 seconds this is the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
trying to remember all the things you
boycotted can really get you stressed
because there's no good way to keep them
from becoming a cluttered mess well now
there's boycott binder the ingenious
organizer that keeps track of everything
and everyone you've ever boycotted the
72 category filing system makes it easy
to organize boycotted people places and
things so you can find them with ease
the large centered area can even fit
your boycott sign but best of all when
you're done the boycott binder folds
right up so you can take it anywhere so
if you're tired of having a cluttered
mess call now and get the boycott binder
for just 29.99 plus you'll also receive
our next rep as a bonus just Loop it
around your neck to travel with ease but
call right now and we'll double the
offer that's two boycott binders and two
neck straps for just 29.99 boycott
binders brought to you by the same
makers of binders full of women
I'm back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
welcome back to the show it is Friday
Friday Friday September 8th you know
what that means in the second hour bone
head of the week
bonehead of the week
this this segment is going to be more
mean more in the coming weeks than you
know
the reason why is because bonehead of
the week is where you will come watch me
and Gabe Sanchez together because there
is news in the [__] fam Universe Gabe
Sanchez is going to be having his own
one hour live show on Tuesdays
Wednesdays and Thursdays right after
this show Gabe how excited are you about
your new um I'm pretty pumped man are
you I'm pretty pumped is Satan yeah
Satan's pretty pumped he loves a good
episode of what was that so he's in full
support of me doing a show on Tuesday
Wednesday Thursday
um yeah he's been emailing you and he's
excited about it Satan's been email he's
actually the one who's like you gotta do
your own show man you gotta yeah is that
what this was it was Satan who gave you
this idea
well you know sitting on the shoulder
saying on the shoulders the other you
know devil in the angel yeah
but uh yeah I'm I'm pretty excited uh
yeah next week will be the first week
the following week after that touch and
go because I'm traveling but then it's
back to normal great but yeah Tuesday
Wednesday Thursday next week one hour
live public show people live live live
pretty strongly they enjoyed the the
weekend Roundup that I do
um and we threw I so so because I do my
weekend show right before yours
and somehow I think the audience kind of
planned that for us they're like hey you
guys just need to do it like together so
this was kind of their idea right and
and you guys have been calling for it
you guys have been calling for three
hours for like the last I don't know a
year and a half
um that we've been doing two hours
you're like three as soon as we did two
hours you're like no we need three and
I'm like Jesus Christ which we do we
need about 12 hours to get through all
the [__] that these people do every
day but that you know we ain't got that
kind of time but here's the thing yeah
is that uh
uh we for the last three weeks we did
the patreon and I threw to you even
though your microphone kind of you know
hit the hit the fan on the first one I
think that was the first one right that
was the first try right out of the gate
first try it was but we but we but we
picked it up quite uh well we we got we
got we got it back together the next two
and it worked really well the audience
loved to go to from one to the other
without having to change anything on
YouTube
um and we'll be doing the same thing on
Twitch so the YouTube and twitch should
be able to go uh do one right after the
other and and they really liked it and I
think it gave you the idea that hey we
could do that during the week and I I
think it's a I think it's excellent that
we can expand to more time for the
audience to see and different content a
different way of doing it like you're
you know you there's so many stories
that you miss on what was that
um that is gonna be able to you're gonna
be able to take care of some of those on
the live show
yeah it's just a revolve and like you
know I look at the news and and current
events as a revolving door of just like
[__] [__] that's coming out and it's
almost good it's fast too and it's
[__] it's yeah it's it the thing is
malfunctioning and it's [__] spinning
like a carousel
um and so keeping up with it to do
because you know it takes me time to
write and film and edit what was that
episode so there's a lot of effort that
goes into that so this would at least
allow me to cover smaller stories that
have not yet gotten to the point where
I'm like I need to dedicate a full
episode to this this allows everyone to
follow along as I cover
so Tyler are you going to cover it so
now are you going to cover stuff that
you can't get to with what was that but
you're going to be kind of following
along with with what is going to be a
what was that as well yeah so you'll be
able to follow you know the inner
workings of my mind where you know we
might go down oh God I know I know look
a little Justice
I've seen the inner workings in in
private chats with Gabe's ninjas and
holy moly it's going to be an
interesting hour that's for sure yeah
100 I hope everyone's ready but if
you're ready to go down the rabbit hole
with me Alice then let's have a [__]
game of it that's great that's great I'm
excited I'm excited too next week
um to be having three hours on Tuesday
Wednesday Thursday to throw to you and
and see what what the audience makes of
um again the we're inner workings of
game Sanchez's mind and how the what was
that uh becomes becomes a thing so I'm
excited excited about that but let's get
to bonehead of the week
[Music]
[Applause]
bonehead of the Gabe's gone he what what
happened I didn't kick him out I promise
I didn't kick him out I don't know what
the hell happened
it was like kind of was like and I was
like all right I'm gonna do it oh I see
so you weren't it did wasn't back by the
time the music stopped because it was
just me here yeah I had it ready to go
but I don't have the timing right man
that works that works that works you
better have the timing right next week
man now now for the audience to know
bone of the week Gabe's gonna be here
with me on Fridays for a moment of the
week and we're going to continue to do
bonehead of the week together for at
least for now until you can't have
enough time that you got to do more what
was it and you're gonna be on the show
on Monday in the second hour so Gabe's
still going to be on the show on Monday
in the second hour and on Friday now
he'll he'll come in on Tuesday Wednesday
Thursday a couple times to tell you what
he's going to talk about on his show uh
so you'll get you'll get some Gabe there
as well so don't don't be scared because
that's one thing like Oh No Escape not
gonna be on the show anymore no no no no
he's not leaving anything we're still
all in the same [__] Universe here
and we're just we're just expanding it
so yeah
Cinematic Universe that's good the F the
FCU yeah that's good that's good the f I
mean I guess you could call him the [__]
em universe and then just fu yeah the f
u that's beautiful that's beautiful
that's what's gonna happen see this is
how these ideas uh propagate here on on
the Tony Michaels podcast and bone of
the week speaking of bone of the week we
have plenty of boneheads uh to go around
oh yeah Enrique tario one of the
boneheads I really thought he was going
to another mother
uh is this is this his mug shot is that
his mug shot that his mug shot okay and
then we have every other photo every
other photo that he's taken online or
has been taken of him has been him with
sunglasses and a hat on and sometimes
he's smoking a cigarette because he's
such a [__] bed he's so cool he's so
cool speaking of not being cool the vake
the snake Rama Swami and uh you know
truth really true truly hit him on the
head the other day like literally at
that yeah and treason oh yeah no it the
truth sign bit makes a makes a cameo in
this what was that right right you know
I mean a lot of here's I'll say this the
what was that that's on Vivek ramaswamy
a lot of it is done just by many uh
Hassan's well we're gonna we're gonna
show part of that clip because that's
the that's the biggest bonehead thing
that I think not just the the true
thing's pretty good that's pretty good
like like these mangas are like oh we
need a sign from Q like well there's
your [__] sign dude you don't
literally on a dude's show who writes a
book with the title win every argument
persuading in public speaking okay you
do not do it you don't go on a show and
think hey you know what I've got a real
fighting shot here right well and the
vague he has a fighting shot in this
poll today
is it pretty well in this bowl yeah he
did pretty good uh Tucker Carlson
speaking of
not doing well at all Tucker Carlson
really tried this week he tried really
hard Gabe he tried really hard to make
people believe that Barack Obama was gay
I mean so much so that even Dave
portnoy's like what yeah okay that's
crazy not I did not have that one on my
bingo card when I first started reading
the Tweet which will show I was like
uh oh like I thought at first I was like
oh I honestly forget him when I was on
set and I was like
oh this this took a turn I did not
expect well I when I read it I wasn't
surprised and the reason why is because
of I've seen a couple videos of this guy
what's the guy's name that's accusing
Obama what's this guy's name something
Larry Sinclair yeah there it is Larry
Sinclair it reminds me of a Sinclair Gas
Station you remember those with the
[__] dinosaur and [__] anyways I know
about Sinclair like media broadcast well
right yeah that too but
yeah definitely not if you've heard this
guy talking like no [__] way is this
guy involved with those people but but
it reminds me of the dinosaur because I
figured the dinosaur's name is probably
Larry and it's like Larry Sinclair so
that's that's where I get it that's why
it kind of like jolts in my mind when
the name Larry Sinclair that I I don't
remember the name but I remember the
logo right and I don't know the name
either I don't know if it's actually
Larry the dinosaur but again I just
figured that the dinosaur's name might
be Larry I could see how they're like no
it's Larry the dinosaur you know I mean
I don't even think there's Sinclair Gas
Stations anymore but there's Sinclair
Gas Stations I don't know yeah I
remember I remember the dinosaur but
yeah thinking back to it now I'm like oh
that's kind of [__] up like you gotta
get dinosaur on there and I mean it's no
different than somebody being like
here's my egg company and I have a
chicken on it but right right it's kind
of weird I think it's funny they're like
oh and this is where the oil comes from
it's kind of weird but you know that's
not good exactly so so Dave Portnoy did
this you know what let's just start
there let's just start there um Carlson
and Dave Portnoy and the Larry
Singularity the dinosaur Larry
Sinclair's yeah um thing if you have the
Portnoy uh tweet there yeah yeah because
I think I liked it
you're like like
weird to be in a universe where you have
to like it I hit that I hit the like
button and I was like
um
other people did that I know too so so
it might not be advanced
yeah it might not be so weird might not
be there all right yeah let me find it
but but the um I'm not surprised that
day portnery actually said this and the
reason why I'm not surprised that he
said this is because who this guy is
right because this guy is not bar stool
type material right now he's saying bar
stool type stuff that they want to hear
but he's not this guy this Larry
Sinclair is not not a voice that the the
stoolies would go yeah that sounds like
someone I want to listen to because he
doesn't have any [__] teeth this guy
looks and he just
he really looks like meth had a really
good friend for a long time if you want
to know Leon well I mean he admitted to
doing
drugs
in the in the attempt to uh to go after
Obama in this interview right well you
know it's kind of weird it's kind of
weird because Obama has admitted to
doing cocaine right I mean he's admitted
publicly to doing cocaine uh so it's not
a secret that is like and he's like and
he admitted to smoking wheat and he's
like the point's inhale right right so I
I don't I don't think that it's wildly
out of
um yeah the Public's fear that Obama did
cocaine I don't think because he's
admitted to it right so yeah Obama doing
drugs that most of the people that
you've met in your life maybe people on
the show have done
cocaine
definitely
this guy look you know sometimes you
just need a good bump you know right and
you're not saying this week just last
week no no no no no no last week you
might I'm saying somewhere in the past
I'm saying somewhere in the past right
well here's Dave's uh Tweet now if you
don't know Dave Portnoy is he's the El
Presidente that's what he calls himself
of Barstool Sports and if you don't know
anything about Barstool Sports well
I would say that the majority of
Barstool Port were Sports probably at
one point had a Maga flag somewhere and
Dave Portner also interviewed Donald
Trump while he was in office I don't
know if anyone knows that
uh Dave portno also for anyone who's in
the Midas touch University Portnoy
accused
um Midas Touch of a hit job on Joe Rogan
uh using Patriot takes which is
hilarious because Alex Jones actually
made the video Patriot shakes just
posted the video on Twitter that Alex
Jones made of Joe Rogan saying the
n-word with the hard R and then Dave
Portner was really for sure that it was
some sort of
cabal type plan to get rid of Joe Rogan
even though Alex Jones is the one who
made the video and it was it was public
they just had to find it and repost it
he's a gay porno he's a [__] bonehead
he's a [__] bonehead you know it's
it's the classic victimies you know
right fluent in it and when it comes to
anything I've done previously it's going
to be that uh no that didn't really
happen uh that's manipulated that
spliced uh that's edited uh it's done in
a way that doesn't make me look good and
I uh uh uh it's it's all that and he
does that too Dave Portner in here
several months in go there was a expose
on him and he act like they were lying
he was releasing text messages that
actually showed that he was [__]
lying but there's all kinds of [__] with
Dave Portnoy and basically he's a
misogynistic piece of [__] who who loves
to have misogynistic pieces a [__] talk
about sports and yeah and they they've
created this uh this this Macho Empire
as it is around Sports
but even him even this [__] bonehead
is like this Larry Sinclair Guy this is
when it came through my feed and I saw
the first line I was like I I assumed he
was going to say something completely
different right and then as as I read
the second line I had to read it again
to understand
oh wait he's not saying what I thought
he was gonna say right and then the rest
of it I was like oh yeah here's what he
said here's what day Portner said and he
re he quote tweeted the interview that
Tucker Carlson posted on Twitter of
Larry Sinclair accusing Obama
was the last person on Tucker Carlson's
show right and one he's he alludes to
that in the Tweet here but here's the
thing too is that
first off what does it matter of Obama's
gay number one whatever the matter of
eating it appears man if he smoked crack
and did some coke I mean Mike Lindell is
a crack user and they act like he's
great so what the [__] the difference
and that's and that's the and that is
the key thing right there it goes to
how
Republicans are easily able to look at
them themselves and say oh no we sinned
and were able to be forgiven because of
God and you know what we're recovering
and we're born again why can't Obama
like Lindell
I know I know well for a few reasons the
main reason is maybe the skin color oh
oh he's black oh I see yeah but not only
that but then they're like Obama Muslim
ah Hussein you know they'll love to say
Barack Hussein Obama like right it's
like everyone's got a [__] name man
everyone's got a middle name mostly
unless you change your name to one word
like Madonna or Liza or Prince or
whatever or there yeah yours is Prince
the elzebub right in that your middle
name
yes
I'm just assuming I mean if middle names
I'll say this I don't know how you
figured out my government name
but thanks for doxing me bro
um so Dave porno here docs is uh Larry
Sinclair's credibility here he really
does he says I met Larry Sinclair when I
was doing my Tucker thing I love how
he doesn't say Tucker's show I love that
he's like my Tucker thing like even even
when they're getting Dave Portner to
come on his stupid Twitter show they're
like he's like so what is it they're
like well it's a it's a thing that we do
on Twitter like gay porn knows what
shows is he produces all kinds of
podcasts and shows and he literally says
doing my Tucker thing whatever the hell
it is whatever the hell that thing is I
mean he could have just said you know
when I was doing Tucker's show right
my Tucker thing so he's already I just
wanna I
I think I think going forward yeah
everyone that's in the chat on the
Discord whenever we talk about Tucker's
show we call it Tucker's thing Tucker
yeah Tucker's thing yeah protector
called Tucker's thing yeah
and Dave I I will cave you on the show
man if Dave sees this I'll have you on
the show I mean it ain't it ain't gonna
be fun for you but I'll be on the show
you'll get to yell and scream at me and
call me a Libby I'm just hoping that he
comes on with pizza and he reviews yeah
sure absolutely but he says that's what
El Presidente does right review Pizza
yeah and has nothing to do with anything
else doing my Tucker thing a couple
weeks ago
I would trust Anna develop delving and
it yeah anadelby Annie Anna delvey
before I trusted anything Larry Sinclair
said top two bottom maybe at least
trustworthy the least trustworthy human
I've ever laid my eyes on Could It Be
The Meth mouth I don't know
I'd say his story is 0.0 of being true
and that's generous
oh my God so tell the audience why he
who Anna Delby is and why it is so
[__] important that Larry Sinclair is
less trustworthy than Anna delvey so
Anna delvey aka Anna Sorokin I think is
what her last name is her real last name
uh she's a con artist she was basically
counting a bunch of people in New York
City she pretended to be uh this wealthy
heiress to you know she was an upper
class New York socialite there's
actually a movie uh I think it's or a
show it's a it's a series it's a series
on Netflix and it's it's about Anna
delvey and it's actually played by the
actress who's from uh Ozark yeah
she plays uh I can't think of the
character's name right now but she plays
the very smart very talented she's great
and so she she played these are great it
is a great series I watched the Anna
devil well yeah what's what is the end
of the lb series called on Netflix I
forget them uh I forget what it's called
I think it's like uh I forget what it's
called but we'll forget that but Anna
yeah and that's it and and yeah and and
and Anna delvey is a serious con artist
and not only like so much so that she
kind of conned herself is kind of what
the the series portrays so she kind of
conned herself even that's how great of
a con she is kind of like that that was
like she's like what you wearing you
look like [__] right
[Laughter]
I guess if she really said that but the
crazy part did I wonder if Dave Portnoy
ever met Anna in person he might have no
matter what I mean she swindled a ton of
people right and maybe he's got some
kind of thing against her because she
swindled him maybe even I don't know I
mean hey if Dave comes on I'll ask him
about that but Anna delvey Anna delvey
is way more trustworthy than than lyric
and I love I love Dave I love how you
put it man that that he's the least
trustworthy human you've ever laid your
eyes on and Grant you he's interviewed
Donald Trump folks yeah this guy I
believe set belly to belly with Trump
okay I believe it was
a tweet and it was by Don Jr and I
remember this specifically and I've only
because of what he said he was like um
something to the effect of oh my God
look at this
El Presidente is interviewing the
president and he goes nowhere else would
he ever see this yeah and it was a photo
of Donald Trump
Dave Portnoy
Don Jr maybe Eric I don't know but I
know at least those three right right
well and again Tucker Carlson is one of
our contestants of bonehead of the week
because he let Larry Sinclair on his
show and spew his life that's what he
that's what Tucker Carlson has left to
he has no other option but to bring
these insane stories and people on
because
the way that I look at Tucker Carlson I
mean even before when he was on Fox News
there was some legitimacy to the fact
that he was on a major a major cable
network but it was the audience it's the
audience that he's talking to so you got
to remember he was talking to a
different audience on Fox News than he's
talking to on Twitter yes and even knows
Ryan he knows that Twitter is again I've
said this ADHD on [__] crack here not
the same crack that Larry Sinclair did
but you know crack now similar it's kind
of similar
it
honestly could be the same it could be
the same uh same batch but what I will
say is
the way that Tucker Carlson has created
to or has created or morphed his show
he's realized that politics
is not always a winning strategy on
Twitter for him especially as he's done
longer interviews so what he ends up
doing is he tries to wrap it up
and basically he just like [__] wrapped
up in a bow and the content that he
creates on this thing is crazy
outlandish wild conspiracy theories that
have been debunked or disproven or have
no merit whatsoever this story
specifically owes Obama gay it turns out
there was this thing he rubbed my leg
and I gave him 250 dollars and I just
wanted to see where it went
it dude
it's amazing and it's not only that but
you look at other people like Ben
Shapiro Ben Shapiro
seems to be doing this interesting thing
and I'm noticed on Twitter is any time
an episode comes out of Tucker's thing
then
but whenever an episode comes out look
at Ben Shapiro because then he comes in
and he doubles down and goes yeah what's
so weird about this isn't it strange
that we've done these other things but
we're not going to do this and this
specific moment he was like why can't we
believe Larry Sinclair we believed other
people who came forward against
Kavanaugh and uh Eugene Carroll against
Trump which is not even the same
accusations I'm trying to legitimize not
even the same as you guys who has been
disproven right is again this I think
the first claim that came out from Larry
Sinclair was 2008 2007 2008 and it's
been disproven for the last 15 years
well that's why Tucker had to bring him
on is because they had he had to revive
this thing because there's plenty of
people now on the the myth of Twitter
that batch of meth that um you know
Larry Sinclair was on that weren't on
the batch of meth in 2008 because yeah
they were little bitty uh teenage boys
they were a little bitty teenage white
boys and they've gotten into their 20s
and now they're just you know white in
cells on Twitter thinking that they're
crypto Bros that actually reminds me
back in 04 and 08 there was a guy
um man he wasn't on Fox News he wasn't
really a Republican
uh but he was supporting the Democratic
party he even supported Al Sharpton at
one point really really what was his
name is he a bonehead this week he is a
bonehead this week yeah uh yeah it's
right that's right it was Tucker Carlson
everyone classic
okay so we got we got around Tucker out
of the way here now we're gonna go to
Enrique atarium this isn't going to take
long with Enrique tario because uh the
the reason why he's a bonehead this week
is because he [__] around and he found
out uh Enrique Enrique tario was a
sentence to 20. can you give me that the
video of him and Stuart Rhodes I know
you got that one handy I want to show I
want to show the world why Enrique
agario was sentenced to 22 years in
prison with the terrorists still thought
that it wasn't enough the prosecutors
were asking for 33. uh judge Kelly Who
was appointed by um
Trump the guy that uh Enrique Charlie
was trying to overthrow the government
uh for
um actually sentenced a judge Kelly
sentenced Enrique tario to the 22 years
in federal prison
um and a lot of people thought that it
wasn't enough which I actually don't
believe it's enough I think I think you
should receive a life sentence uh when
you commit domestic terrorism and the
act of trying to overthrow our
government I believe that should survey
you know there's a couple important
things to remember here is one
this is not the maximum sense you know
that the prosecutors were suggesting
into the judge that that gave that
issued the sentence to Enrique tario
is a trump judge right he's Trump
appointed judge so this is not political
or any of that [__] or he's not a
political if you've got a problem take
it up with Trump man right Enrique
agario uh Rick atario is a domestic
terrorist and here he is shown in the
act of planning this seditious
conspiracy uh with his as the leader of
the group of The Proud boys with other
groups but in particular Stuart Rhodes
who is the leader of the oath keeper who
also received 18 years uh for his ACT in
this domestic terrorism to overthrow our
government and the United States here's
a little excerpt uh from this is a
British News Channel right yeah and
actually I have the
the version we can play this but I also
have the version of the clip where it's
not edited well let's let's play this
one here this one we got
it pleasure
Pleasures online
he's joined by Stuart Rhodes founder of
The Oath Keepers militia several of his
members have also been arrested and
prosecutors allege some Oath Keepers may
have been planning the attack as early
as November Rhodes himself has not been
arrested
but this was before Stuart Roseville
this is a foreign was arrested and
charged uh because this event here in
this little is what's funny about this
is these [__] idiots film themselves
doing this [__] they had a documentary
code that was literally filming them uh
committing sedition and planning
sedition after they had been planning it
for months and months and months and the
main thing the main reason why Enrique
hreo received 22 years is because not
only was he the leader of the proud boys
at the time and he was the leader behind
uh the domestic terrorist Act of of the
Insurrection at January 6th but the
thing is is that Donald Trump on the
stage with Joe Biden when asked
the groups that he would ask he said
proud boys he said stand back and stand
by now this is the and and another I
think it was actually
uh mentioned during the January 6th
committee hearings they said after
Donald Trump said that line during the
debate against Joe Biden there was an
uptick in membership signups well that's
because the proud boys used that as a
way to uh increase that Donald Trump
says come on come on come on that's
right so they used it uh in in effort to
recruit people for the domestic
terrorist Act of the Insurrection at
January 6th I overthrow our government
here's another video the longer unedited
video I want you to remember
do you need a vehicle
they know what you're driving
do they know what you're driving it
doesn't matter I I'm sure that even if
they were to come by right now I'm on my
way out so okay so the reason why
they're saying this uh him and the uh
the lady here the leader yeah yeah
Bianca is so worried right and the
reason why is because Enrique Taria was
not supposed to be in Washington DC he
was barred from being in Washington DC
so he was being in a DC to meet to
collude and to conspire with other
domestic terrorists to commit domestic
terrorist acts against our government
um and the reason why they're so worried
is because he is there against a court
order in DC and there's probably I don't
know it seemed like maybe maybe there
was a reason now why he was barred from
DC because remember it was earlier that
morning the D.C judge said get the [__]
out right do not come back right and if
you look people can look into what he
did in terms of you know burning the the
black lives matter flag at the church
and all that stuff and
what ended up getting him kicked out of
DC so this is why he's like oh even if
they saw me I would say that I'm leaving
and I'm right I'm heading out right so
let's let's finish the clip here oh I
literally just picked up my bags so I
thought they told you
they didn't want the reason why they did
that is that they didn't want me to go
to
tomorrow's event
wonder what it could be I'm gonna go
yeah I'm gonna stay close just to make
sure my guys are okay
so tomorrow and I got I got a lot of
stuff to do tomorrow
yeah he's got a lot of stuff to do
tomorrow he's got to direct his [__]
troops to go commit sedition at the
Capitol which means let me see if I can
find let me see if I can find the Tweet
uh but it's the it's it's the the excuse
that I've heard again and again and
again from everyone which is Enrique
atario wasn't at the Capitol now granted
some people
um have tweeted they're like oh well
that's what he gets for showing up and
it's like no he wasn't even there
and for the people who are like he
wasn't even there
totally correct you are correct however
they're on the other side of the other
side people who are like he wasn't even
there he how could how could he be
involved he wasn't even in there and
they're taking the other side which is
because he wasn't there physically means
that he wasn't at all part of the
planning the logistics the organ that's
why they were so focused when he was
like I'm gonna go to the Virginia side
she's like wait or are you going to the
Virginia the Maryland side it's like the
Maryland side why would we go to the
Maryland side like that doesn't make any
sense logistically if we need you and
it's like my men I'm gonna be in contact
with like it just again this isn't a
totally innocent conversation of hey I
have to leave DC because the judge told
me to and then they're like okay well
what what state are you going to be in
where are you going to be located if we
need to get in contact with you and the
best part of this whole thing is the
fact that they are being [__] filmed
and they know they're they paid to be
filmed I mean they're like yeah sure
come film us yeah you know they are
totally totally fine with a camera being
there we're like oh the camera doesn't
even exist I'm [__] this is [__]
reality TV I'm just waiting to do my
[__] talking head testimonial do you
know why do you know why because they
thought they were going to get away this
they really thought they were gonna and
they thought Donald Trump is going to
protect your stone exactly he's like ah
no big deal let's film all this [__]
right he's gonna go down the history
Trump's gonna win he's going to be the
king and uh he'll he'll protect me um
I'm gonna have to move on I would like
to play more than Ringgit Jerry but we
really need to move on uh to other
boneheads of the week I really have to
play this clip of our Alpha cook Peter
Navarro yesterday Peter Navarro's uh got
here twice this week
what do you mean did it happen twice
this week to him uh no I think it was
three times actually it was three times
yeah I think it was or is it twice this
weekend once last week
um
it gets away from me doesn't it but
Peter Navarro yesterday was heckled
again but the most important thing here
the most important thing let's see is
this the one is this the one that went
um yeah that's not the one I went this
is the one I want
um because there's so many clips from
yesterday now Peter Navarro uh was found
guilty in condempt of Congress in his
trial which is not surprising and it
shouldn't be surprising to him or no one
else and the reason why it gave Sanchez
because he presented no
uh defense because he presented no
evidence or well his only evidence was I
wrote a book about it it's in the book
well you know that is a great reason why
you'd be found guilty from a jury if
you're just like I mean go find my book
honestly that is honestly the only
excuse he gave last June and July and
August when he was doing these like a
medley of interviews on different shows
Ari melbours stand out to me the most
because that's where he actually
admitted there's one interview and I
wish I had the clip if we had if you can
find it in the meantime I'll play it
it's where Ari melber asked him like
just the point where he asked him he's
like you realize you just described a
coup right and and Peter Mars I got it I
got it no no I I don't I don't I I
didn't say that that's not what I did
right but let's watch how Peter Navarro
could say nothing yesterday because this
sweetheart lady who owns a whistle and a
sign he's so he's ow God is Kryptonite
his protesters here and a whistle let's
listen
um
yeah yeah
all right so he has as much to say in
his press conference as he had in his
defense really I mean let's be honest
this is this is about this is about the
defense that he had but let's keep
listening and see if he
says anything
yeah he said he said yeah he said yeah
you got to give him credit he said one
word let's see if he says any other
words into that microphone where he set
up the press conference on a public
sidewalk where he could just have a
private press conference to not have
this this uh insanity but he's an idiot
so this is what idiots do
the man talks charges are you interested
in hearing him no one's not really not
really not really
[Laughter]
oh [__] Peter and let's just let's
just let's just clear the air here no
one is stopping Peter Navarro from
Talking he can talk people he can say
whatever I mean he's got microphones in
front of him so I mean the microphones
are going to pick up what he's well
there's no real I mean yeah because yeah
those mics are going to pick up anything
within the you know right 180 degrees
but he's closest to the mic so he can
get loud and you know he could be loud
and proud over them but they're like oh
let him speak
the only person that is stopping Peter
Navarro from speaking is Peter Navarro
right just like every other Republican
like Marjorie Taylor green and everyone
else you know there's that joke from
um
death to 2020 where Lisa coudreau goes
on as what looks like a Margaret Taylor
green type of personality and she's like
the right or the the left wing the
Democrats are trying to silence me and I
said it on the podcast with Joe Rogan
and I said it on my interview on Fox
news with Tucker Carlson and I said it
on my you know during my book and I said
it in my this and that and I said it and
this and that no one is stopping any of
these people from speaking the only
people that are stopping themselves well
the only people that are stopping them
are themselves
or they're not stopping themselves like
he did here on Ari melber show this is
hilarious watch this clip it doesn't
take long to get to uh the coup part but
launch the plan was simply this we had
uh over a hundred congressmen and
Senators on Capitol Hill ready to
implement the suite there would be
enough concern amongst the legislatures
that most or all of those States would
would decertify the election that would
throw the election to the House of
Representatives you will use the
incumbent losing party's power that was
the Republican party that was losing
power to overtake and reverse that
outcome do you realize you are
describing a coup
no I I totally reject many of your
premises the election it doesn't matter
if you reject his premises or not you
know what's funny about this interview
this literally started the the uh the
investigation into Peter Navarro and the
plan that he laid out on Ari melbour's
show for the January 6th select
committee when he called it the Green
Bay sweep like they even had a [__]
name for it yeah and they were like whoa
whoa what you had a Green Bay what and
and he laid it out in public and Ari
Melbourne's like you know you probably
shouldn't have said that whole coup
thing out loud the craziest part about
this whole thing is after he went on Ari
melbour's show and did that he continued
to go back to our members show and
continue to be able he went on like
another one or two times after that and
Ari's like let's play the clip where you
said you were planning a coup right
right he plays the clip it's Insanity so
that's why Peter Navarro is cooked today
by the woman with the sign and the
whistle she's after my heart truly
everyone should be in love with her
because she's doing us all a service and
she's a patriot and Peter Navarro is
this week's bone of the week's Alpha
cuck now let's get to the dishonorable
mention uh lady G Lindsey Graham oh my
God that was the news when we woke up
this morning is that Lindsey Graham the
United City United States center from
South Carolina who is not a senator in
Georgia although the other two senators
that were sitting at the time were also
recommended for indictment from the
special grand jury so so this morning
wake up and they're like hey there's
three United States senators that are on
the list of the special grand jury in
Georgia not the criminal one that did
invite them but the special grand jury
you know the little lady that was on TV
um that one there three sitting United
States Senator at the time uh that they
were doing these acts so Lindsey Graham
uh Purdue David Perdue of Georgia and
waffler Kelly loffler of Georgia were
all recommended for indictment now it
doesn't stop there those are the three
United States senators
um that were chosen to be recommended
for indictment but you added Michael
Flynn uh squirrel turd uh Len wood did
you know that world turds are really
jealous of how nutty Lynnwood aren't
squirrel that's our [__] job yeah
Linwood he's a cool I jeez you think
Julie Green's a [__] Wackadoo that
profit oh [__] she doesn't own the
candle to Linwood anyways uh Linwood is
another one Mike Flynn General Trader
Mike Flynn did you know hey did you know
what I [__] yesterday I took a big old
[__] yesterday yeah and it smelled so
bad I named it Mike Flynn
it smelled like a traitor what do you
want from me it smelled like a traitor
so next time next time I get a [__]
hemorrhoid I'm gonna name it Mike Flynn
I mean these [__] piece of [__] is a
real pain in my ass right now
um what's this clip you sent me here
this is uh
is this Lindsey Graham yeah this is
Lindsey Graham it's a 26 second clip oh
okay so uh let's see what Lindsay has to
say here in this clip uh let's hear it
lady G
at the end of the day nothing happened
what I did was consistent with my job as
being a United States Senator chairman
of the Judiciary Committee well but it
was just not me
three United States senators
we're opening up Pandora's Box I think
the system this country is getting off
the rails and we have to be careful not
to use the legal system as a political
tool
listen if you would stop committing
crime Republicans if you would stop
doing that we wouldn't have to use the
judicial and the courts to prosecute you
for the [__] political crimes you're
committing political why don't you
understand this it's political because
you're committing political crimes you
[__] dumb [__] boneheads
Lindsey Graham
it's a great excuse other people were
charged or potentially charged and they
weren't just like me like what how does
that make any sense other people are
investigated and recommended to be
charged with crimes and they weren't we
really opened up Pandora's Box
dude yeah you did that as soon as you
tried to go down to Georgia or have a
phone call with Georgia to say hey we
gotta get rid of these legally casted
mail-in ballots
you were questioning you start removing
ballots like that then we're getting
into election interference so right you
weren't just questioning the results you
were asking them to change the results
you [__] scumbag Lindsey Graham and I
am calling today and every day after
this for Lindsey Graham to resign as a
United States Senator and to never hold
office ever again for his role in
election interference in Georgia where
he was recommended by a special grand
jury to be indicted on Ricoh charges so
[__] you Lindsey Graham forever you
[__] piece of [__]
um I can't believe you let the blackmail
and dictate how you do it now
oh my God speaking of
feckless idiots Vivek
Vivek excuse me the fake the snake
ramaswami uh maybe he steps on a rake I
don't know did you know we have um well
there's a rake there is a rake mentioned
at in the pot in the in the episode as
well so just okay do you got the um the
the clip of him getting hit by the sign
because that's that is the funniest
that's the funniest one but I'm also uh
so I'm gonna play that one but I'm gonna
go to the uh Mindy uh uh interview here
that he had on MSNBC and it's really
funny because it's about
um vivex tax returns and how he's a
[__] liar and it just uh fact checks
him in real time it's beautiful so let's
take a listen
you say you were anti-identity politics
anti-affirmative action in a party that
hates the Sorrows name yet you accepted
a Paul and Daisy Soros scholarship at
Law School law school that was
specifically set up for the children of
the immigrants it was an affirmative
action scholarship and your defense for
that is that you didn't have the money
to pay for law school even though you'd
already made over a million dollars at
the time
scholarship at the age of 24.
scholarship you take it I didn't say I
didn't have the money I said at a time
when I had a lot less money than now
fifty thousand dollars
you keep forgetting your quote you said
when I don't have the money
so so many I've made this really easy
for everybody and I did this in the
early weeks of the campaign yeah I
released 20 years of tax returns yes
something that no presidential candidate
let alone somebody who's successful in
business challenge Democrats and
Republicans alike family to do it
I released it so that you could look at
them so we can have it into this
conversation I do appreciate that
transparency is important so his his two
reasons everybody can see it exactly we
have two thousand dollars
in 2010 you made 750 000 you had the
money to pay for law school you didn't
need a Soros affirmative action
scholarship that you now
none of this is worthy but if you think
it is let's get to the detail that was
actually the first one
scholarship for immigrants
so why'd you take a scholarship
which falsehood would you like me to
address the financial one or the or the
one about life
not not at the time that I had applied
that fall yesterday
it's not awkward for you yes on December
31st when the application for the
scholarship was that October midi you're
wasting your time on childish details in
October that's applied for that
scholarship
and it was well guess what the bonuses
that a hedge fund pays and it's it's a
shame that again you don't have to be an
expert on this but if you're gonna spout
out you better know something about it
people pay at a hedge fund the bonuses
at the end of the year and on December
31st that's when I was paid I apologize
[Music]
or whatever it was
no you didn't you're now selling flat in
2009 you made 650 000 in 2010 you made
less 450 000 so the argument that you
only made a scholarship free this so now
we're bringing taxider we've been using
gross yeah absolutely okay so it goes on
in the course
um it's truly amazing
again like I went through this for uh
what was that and I'm editing it right
now
and there are so many good moments I had
a difficult like I covered the range of
topics during their interview but I
gotta say man it was so difficult to
figure out which parts to pull out for
each moment or each topic they discussed
because
as much that when I want to be like hey
watch this three minute clip now watch
this other three minute clip now watch
this other three minute clip I can't do
that
but there are so many in the 25 minute
full extended interview
because the only reason I think if he
only released a few Clips on on Twitter
but the full extended interview that's
25 minutes holy [__] man it is Non-Stop
and I break it all down
um in the what was that I talk about a
strategy I talk about why he does what
he does and of course this next clip
definitely makes a cameo in it oh well
this is when the truth comes at you hard
uh and knocks you straight down let's
watch uh the truce hit Vivek they
weakened we he spoke at the fair in
Lancaster earlier today and during that
speech the sign behind him actually fell
on him for a moment but this weekend
when the truth literally comes at you
um you know what's funny about this the
the best part about this is not just the
true sign hitting him this is a he's
he's wearing a true social hat so like
when I say he's a Donald Trump op and
he's a plant like literally he's wearing
Donald Trump's social media hat truth
um in an effort to to promote Donald
Trump's platform which only shows you
the obvious truth about Vivek that he's
a total [__] fraud and that he is a
fraud for Trump here and by the way
um I gotta hand it to you I thought the
right wing was going to be the one
really started to smash him with the
with the sorrow stuff but boy the left
wing I don't I don't know if MSNBC
producers are still listening or not
well you guys really caught on when I
said he was going to be knocked with
this sort of stuff from the right and
going after him from the left this is
beautiful because painting painting
Vivek as a Soros uh payment recipient is
is this what the right is going to do to
get rid of him and it's beautiful which
is also crazy because this is something
that uh I don't know I want to say two
months ago you know he was on one of
Mario's spaces and that's when I was on
there and one of the things one of the
other things that I brought up
was this whole I think it was I mean
political might have covered it the
thing is like
this George Soros thing isn't even new
like this has been out for at least
three months or so but the specific part
about it that makes this whole situation
even funnier is the fact that he tried
to scrub it from his Wikipedia page and
so when I brought it up he was like no
no that's that's not that's not it's
that's not what no that's not what
happened that's not what happened and he
tried to you know try to yeah it is it
is it he even does it in this interview
where he's like no no no no they spelled
my wife's name wrong okay that doesn't
mean [__] like right what is that the
money that you took from Soros yeah you
took the money it's on the website your
face is [__] plastered there we all
know that you did it and we also have
evidence from payment and also
conversations or Transit you know they
the reporter who covered the story
originally did all the due diligence and
fact checked and was like yes this was a
communication back and forth he did
request this editor on Wikipedia to
scrub the information not only his
George Soros scholarship but his coveted
era role right he was involved yeah did
he oh so he's a triple bonehead is what
you're saying let's give the fake the
snake who steps on a rake his do
[Music]
[Applause]
it it was closer it was one percent
right it was very very close and Vivek
listen man you barely barely barely beat
the domestic terrorists who tried to
overthrow the government for your new
boss and your new your new king uh
Donald Trump it's really crazy that you
just goes to show you it just goes to
show you when you go and you back Donald
Trump you end up losing or you end up
winning right and our bowl is the
biggest [__] loser and the bonehead
of the week don't go anywhere we have a
few announcements right after this
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
head of the week uh thank you for
joining us today we have a few
announcements real quick next week is
going to be a little different here at
the [__] em fam in the [__] em universe
so don't forget that the schedule is
going to be changing on Mondays and
Fridays you're going to get a pre-hour
if you're a patreon member I'm gonna
talk about this on my Sunday show this
Sunday the Sunday rant it will be live
it will be public I'm gonna go over
where and how all that is gonna work and
how uh the pre-show is gonna take place
and then you have the two hour the Tony
Michaels podcast right here the two hour
show Monday through Friday nothing's
changing about that same exact schedule
but on Tuesday Wednesday Thursday you're
gonna get an extra hour live live live
live with what was that live with Gabe
Sanchez on Tuesdays Wednesdays and
Thursdays so don't forget to go to the
Tony michaels.com follow me follow Gabe
everywhere check out the patreon uh this
Sunday I will be giving you all the
public details Gabe are you gonna do a
patreon this Sunday yeah yeah so you
want to do a public I'll do yeah I'll do
a public one yeah that way we can do all
the announcements and we can get
everything out of the way and we can get
sort all this out so everyone knows
exactly how it's going to work next week
even though we probably won't get it
exactly right we're gonna try we're
gonna try our best to get it exactly
right it is our first go around next
week so tune in on Sunday on patreon go
to patreon.com the Tony Michaels
patreon.com I am Gabe Sanchez or go to
the Tony michaels.com you'll find all
those links there and we will continue
to talk about the schedule um here's
here's that speaking of the vake The
Rake here is let them eat rake go to
store.thetonymichaels.com to get let
them eat rake let them eat Vivek is that
what we should change it to I don't know
doesn't sound appetizing you know what I
mean no no um no don't eat it
so come join us on patreon this
Wednesday's uh this Sunday excuse me
this Sunday uh publicly uh it'll start
at 8 00 p.m Central Gabe will come right
after me so it'll be two hours
I'm gonna come you know they've gotta
they've got a meme of you saying that
over on the Discord oh really yeah yeah
it's about to pop-up
um
that Meme on the Discord not Gabe's
inches right yeah no I can't wait to see
it I haven't seen it there it is
so go over to the Discord you're
definitely I don't know what I was doing
if that was related to that or not so I
just took a freeze frame I'm not really
sure who who could have done that or who
man who might have done that if you
wanna guys are terrible they need Jesus
over there on Discord and they need you
over there on Discord to join the
community I put the Discord uh Link in
the chat there also you can find Gabe
Sanchez's Discord you're going to want
to join that also as well um but go join
the [__] fam in the [__] Universe
over there on Discord it is a great
place make sure to verify when you go in
if you have questions about it if the
directions are in the Welcome Center
just go to the Welcome Center the
directions to to verify are there so go
join Discord join the [__] fam
community over there we're gonna there's
a lot of stuff going on over there as
well and don't forget to subscribe here
on the Tony Michaels podcast because
when you subscribe here next week what's
gonna happen you're going to watch the
Tony Michaels podcast and then it is
automatically going to shoot you into
Gabe Sanchez is what was that live so
you're gonna want to go to the Tony
Michaels the Tony michaels.com and
follow his YouTube channel as well and
it's going to be on Twitch too twitch.tv
Tony Michaels we'll get it to go over
there as well so twitch and YouTube will
shoot right into Gabe jenches show I
have one more thing I got to take care
of business here someone sent a venmo
super chat it was Wilkins uh have you
seen Rhonda DeSantis go off on a black
veteran I have not seen this video yet
but [__] Rhonda that is true [__]
meatball uh maybe maybe I'll have to
find that and I'll have that on the
Sunday rant uh I might have to find that
clip so thank you thank you for the
venmo super chat if you want to get in
on the venmo Super Chat go to the Tony
michaels.com the venmo Super Chat link
is there and I want to thank everyone
again for all the shots that you bought
me this week the shots of Jaeger I'm
gonna put out a video this weekend and
show you guys are you drinking Jaeger
yeah
yeah I I I bought the shots I bought the
shots yeah okay great yeah and I just
threw I just threw my Discord in the
Discord okay good good so go over it's a
little bit you know Inception that's
good that's good so go over to the
Discord again the link is in the chat
everyone have a great weekend join us on
Sunday for all our announcements and all
the plans for next week we'll try to
break it down on the Sunday shows my
Sunday rant and his and Gabe's weekend
Roundup for what was that have a great
weekend don't do anything I wouldn't do
or do the exact things that I would
probably do until next time until Monday
same time same place
Surf's Up [__] you've been
listening to the Tony Michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events and political news no rules No
Boundaries I think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow toning on social media
at the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[__] em
[Music]
's meal Barn head ass Beacon